To test the strength and
durability of your edges,
I'm going to be
taking your blades
and chopping into
these coconuts.
Remember, this test
is all about what
the coconuts do to your
blades, and not what
your knives do to the coconuts.
Alan, you're up.
You ready?
- Absolutely, let's do it.
It puts a lot of pressure
on me having a coconut
chop as the challenge.
The Coconut Empire Forge
was meant to chop coconuts.
We're going to make it happen.
[music playing]
- Whoo-hoo!
- Yes!
Well, Alan, the
handle is really narrow,
but I could hold on
to it really well.
You put a really fine
edge on this blade,
and it picked up a roll
here, and another small one
right next to it.
In all, there's no
chipping, and it held up.
Well done.
ALAN: Thank you.
BEN: Hunter, you're up next.
You ready?
Oh, yeah.
I know I got this one.
This blade's so heavy,
whether it's sharp or not,
it's going through.
But I just gotta hope I maintain
that hard steel on the edge,
and that nothing bad happens.
[music playing]
Yeah, sweet!
Well, Hunter, first off,
your edge held up really well.
It's not super-duper sharp.
I feel pretty safe running
my fingers across here
without getting cut.
But it held up really well.
Tim, you're up next.
You ready?
- Oh, yeah, more than.
I am dying up here.
(LAUGHING) I just want
to see that knife come down.
I want to see coconuts shredded.
[music playing]
As long as the edge
holds up, you're good.
Well, Tim, your edge
held up beautifully.
But for a chopper, this
handle-- it's kind of round.
And on the second coconut,
it just turned in my hand
and glanced off.
But other than that, well done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, this is
the ratchet strap slash.
Now a sharp weapon should
cut cleanly through.
Unlike the coconut test, this
is all about what your blade
does to these straps.
Alan, you're first.
You ready?
Yes sir.
With the damage that I
incurred on the coconut chop,
I'm a little concerned
about how it's going to go
through the ratchet straps.
[music playing]
All right, Alan, let's
talk about your blade here.
It still is sharp.
But your edge took damage
on the strength test.
And when I'm slashing
through these ratchet straps,
you can tell, because some areas
of this-- it tore through it.
Overall, though,
your weapon will cut.
Thank you.
Hunter, you're up next.
You ready?
I guess.
The blade's not as
sharp as I like it.
When they go into that
strap, I'm afraid it's
going to just bounce off.
If it won't even cut a strap,
there's no way I'm moving on.
Yes!
All right, Hunter, let's
talk about your blade here.
When you slice
through it, you can
see that it tore some parts
of this particular strap
right here.
But the weight of this cuts and
pushes through all the weight.
It will cut. ,
Thank you.
Tim, you're up next.
You ready?
As I'm ever going to be.
I'm worried about
my handle indexing.
Because if it rolls, it's
going to glance off, I'm done.
[music playing]
Nice, dude.
I can breathe again.
All right, Tim, let's
talk about your blade here.
First up, your handle.
It's on a smaller narrow
side, but you know what?
It's comfortable when
I grabbed onto it.
Your edge-- it's razor-sharp.
It pretty much cut all the
way through, and it will cut.
Thank god.
DOUG: Good job.
DAVID: All right,
bladesmiths, the judges
have made their final decision.
The bladesmith leaving
the forge is Alan.
Your blade did not make the cut.
Ben's going to tell you why.
Alan, I loved watching you
set up for your [inaudible] But
during the strength
test, your blade took
some pretty serious damage.
And that caused
it to underperform
in the sharpness test as well.
And it's for those
reasons we are
going to have to let you go.
Alan, please
surrender your blade.
ALAN: I agree with
the judge's decision.
My blade incurred just too much
damage striking those coconuts.
This competition has
definitely stoked the fire
of my bladesmithing passion.
And I will continue
to develop skills.
The Coconut Empire has only
lost the battle, not the war.